Cato
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ready for fire time
obviously when your age comes up what
people say is you're so young but so
good so honestly did you envision
yourself being this good at 20 years old
I think the thing that got me to where I
am is just my skill sense I was never
the fastest there's no the most athletic
as I started to get older and stronger
and faster you know it just kind of
caught up with my skill of which I still
got along with his old but I mean I just
didn't think I would get this
opportunity on this big of a stage as
early as it is now so now that you know
where you're at at this moment how good
we've you 27 I can't even imagine myself
it's pretty soon what are you thinking
about right now like see your wheels
turning just how much more efficient and
polished I'll be much bigger
how much more basketball I wasn't
playing things I've been through then
who make me who I am at 27 so long I'm
not in any rush to get older I like
being young so one half of that just to
put into perspective Jason it's you have
been alive the same amount of time that
Vince Carter has been approached is that
like weird to hear yeah everybody likes
to joke with me I young all my teammates
even Rob Rob Williams is a rookie up I'm
still the youngest guy on the team he
just turned 21 a couple weeks ago so how
insurance money I could watch okay now
you said your teammates make fun of you
I gotta take my opportunity to joke
about something here's a year 20 you've
had 21 and March
obviously there was this funny moment
where you were trying to get into your
21 year old Club that's not what
happened okay no explain what happened
please this is your opportunity I was
going in there
TMZ came out of nowhere and he just
started yelling like no he's not he's
not 21 and he just started making a big
scene he they made it look like I
couldn't get in that was my last time I
was trying to go off on the wayside
well we have a total gadget for you some
funny little fake IDs so when you try to
turn to anyone here these are for you we
have the mclovin ID we have your drake
ID i look like great yes
you don't think you pass with old man on
TV see how I might look with a beer
they're not really gonna work wet dry